okay should be recording this is gonna
be a lot different than my normal
YouTube content because most of my other
videos are just uploads of past streams
or parts of past streams and this is
going to be more and more so YouTube
audience and I'll be able to talk
without getting interrupted by any like
follow notifications or people in the
chat so hopefully this will be more
instructive and I've been getting a lot
of questions recently about doing
specific types of videos doing some
series on openings also different like
different questions regarding I don't
know specific areas of chess so
hopefully this video is just a start of
many more exclusively exclusively done
videos for YouTube in which I'll try and
I'll try and bring value to the viewers
I'll try and answer questions for this
video I just want to share kind of a
nice opening from the black side and
we'll actually look from both
perspectives I want to show it from the
black side and then show how to play
against it from the white side and if
you're a hardcore fan it's very possible
that you've seen seen me play this in in
streams but for those who haven't seen
before it starts in a and a Petroff
opening also called the Russian defense
after nine three nine six and after a
night Iggy five there's a move that I
sometimes like to play here in blitz and
of course the main move for black is to
play d6 and afternoon I have three to
take on e4 is all this theory Caruana
has been known for playing it especially
in recent in recent months but the move
I've I've had a lot of fun with is this
movement I take me for and this is
something you see perhaps at beginner
tournaments where the opponent is just
copying their
they're their counterparts and
essentially the main trap that black
walks in choosing it often especially
among beginner play is after a Queenie
to the night will move back and then
let's say nine of six and then black
loses the Queen to Knight c6 however
there is a there's a better way to play
this for black which can lead to a trap
that white can fall into it's to play
this move Queen e7 and then after queen
take four d6 and I will say right away
that this is a dubious opening for black
but a lot of white players won't know
how to best mean it and therefore either
walk into a trap or black will equalize
so let me show that show how whites can
can mess this up most of the time light
will play d4 which is completely fine
realizing that the knight is lost as
there is a pin on efile and white is
simply wanting to get a pawn for the
Knights
so after take on e5 take on e5 black is
down upon now the reason black plays
this is to get some early initiative
because black black has a move here
black can make a threat with knight c6
and now black starts getting initiative
by attacking the opponent e5
now the first time I ever ran into this
opening was actually from I was playing
the white side and this was several
years ago probably about five years ago
I was playing some small open
tournaments and I was playing against an
1800 player
I was probably rated over 2200 at the
time and I played what looked to be the
most natural move here Bishop to f4
which turns out to be a mistake and led
me to two losing a piece very soon so my
opponent played very quickly he was in
his preparation you played pawn g5 which
kind of caught me off guard I spent a
little bit of time here I wanted to keep
this pawn defended I played the most
natural looking move Bishop g3 which is
yet another mistake
Bishop to g3 is is a blender and now
it's black to move in win material so if
you haven't seen this before and you
want to find it pause the video and
finds the material winning move for
black the move is pawn f5 which caught
me completely off guard I realized that
my pawn is pinned so I can't add passant
because the Queen take you for meanwhile
my Queens attacked and blacks
threatening to trap the bishop with f4
so white is just losing a piece here now
what was interesting when I ran into
this my opponent actually offered me a
draw I think what what happened was I
played Queen e2 then my opponent played
f4 and offered me a draw which was maybe
his first mistake his black his better
back should be playing for a win and
when he offered the draw I realized
maybe he wasn't so confident and I went
ahead I played queen h5 check and the
position got messy enough where I did
win the game as White's after something
like King d8 I did lose the bishop pawn
to g3 I won't get into that that
specific game too much but black should
be better here given that there is an
extra piece and it is a matter of
developing the rest of the pieces and
finding some safety for the King I'll be
some idea like Bishop d7 in Bishop g7
but it would still be some fights anyway
after that experience I've trapped a
number of players in this from the
backside just for a fun here we can
check the leech s database and see how
many people have fallen into this from
from the black side let's switch over to
leech s and this position well over 200
games going back to this position 287
games with with pawn f5 with blacks
scoring very well so I usually like to
show this especially when when delving
into opening traps just just to show how
many people can actually fall for some
like this so now I want to go back I
want to show the best response to this
opening because I know there's a lot of
efore players out there and if you're an
e4 player you're probably gonna run into
the Petroff at some points so let's go
all the way back and let's flip the
board flip flip board there we go so I
mean if you're playing against the
petrov you could play Knight c3 if you
want to go into it for Knights I
recommend just taking the pawn and if
you run into this line then the best
move is to play Queen e2 and go into
what we just saw
Queen e7 I mean take e4 d6 d4 take take
nice e6 so same exact line we just saw
but now not to play Bishop to f4 but to
play this move Knight c3 in my opinion
Knight c3 is by far the strongest move
for reasons which we'll see I do want to
make clear that the Bishop e5 is also an
attractive option but after Bishop d7 we
can actually see based on the stats here
that a black is scoring decently at
least in the main line cuz black already
has threats of taking and ideas of
castling queenside so we'll see how
Knights e3 is a much more simple option
so now inevitably black is going to take
back upon I should note here that Knight
takes e5 losses on the spots 295 and
this is just completely winning for
whites as the queen is attacked and the
queen is is tied down to defending both
295 and the pawn on c7 I don't think
there's too much too much black can do
here
maybe Queen as Queen d6 is one
possibility but probably just runs into
f4 and white is winning a piece
otherwise if Queenie six-night 67 if
Queen d7 just queen taking five
so if flock wants to win the pawn it's
most most natural to take with the queen
and now now white will go for the Queen
trade after take take this doesn't look
too impressive at first just because
like the pawn structure is completely
symmetrical and it just seems like a
very try kind of draw position however
white can seize an initiative with next
move next move is very important to play
Bishop to f4 with the skewer and we're
gonna see based on White's kind of
earlier development light will be able
to get the advantage
so after Bishop f4 uh there's a skewer
if the light moves anywhere then Bishop
takes you seven will be played so
there's a couple moves for black
probably the most expected move is
Bishop to d6 if AK wanted to f6 I guess
as possible but could very easily walk
into some lines with with black just
getting an isolated pawn if white wants
to I could probably just take right away
Castle queenside complete development
very naturally and this pawn is just a
long-term weakness this is just a
pleasant edge for whites so Bishop D
specialties most expected and now
there's a very strong move for whites
and if I'm not mistaken there's only one
move in this position for whites to keep
the advantage and I would encourage
viewers if you if you're not sure what
to do here pause the video and try and
find the strongest continuation for
whites
okay so let me start by saying that
light would like to play a move like
night b5 or 94 but these moves don't
work for basically the same reason is
that let's say Y plays and move like 95
it looks strong at first but just walks
into the kind of the positional tactic
Knight f3 allowing the trade of of night
for Bishop after it take take black has
absolutely no problems here the knight
is is really doing nothing on b5 and
black would be very happy with this
position same thing like if white tubs
sorry about that let's go back to this
position if white decided to Castle
queenside here this is also not a great
move because of 93 check and again black
would be getting would be getting the
bishop here so
the thing to do for whites is to simply
stop what black wants to do with the
move Bishop to g3 and this is by far the
most powerful move for organizational
sake we'll make this end mainline and
here the the power of Bishop g3 is white
now has two threats why this threaten
night b5 and 94
with the idea of getting the bishop here
and there's really nothing black can do
to us to stop both of these moves for
example let's say Bach just castles
Knight b5 is incredibly powerful
attacking the bishop
I would assume a move like this should
before is just met with c3 and White
will be maintaining some some nice
advantage here given there's a lot of
pressure against the C pawn pressure
against the night maybe I am a bit
curious what could happen in this line
after Bishop a5 I think what we'll do
because I I didn't prepare this too
extensively um I'll try and figure out
the best move for lights or best
approach for whites and then I'll check
stockfish because I know white has
advantage here it's just a matter of
execution I would like to take on e5
rook e8 and then f4 this could run into
f6
probably Bishop c4 this should be good
enough for whites have some edge for
example if King h8 like a castle take
and then rook 81 this would be my first
my first instincts let's go back let's
see if stockfish has any better
recommendation let's say in this
position stockfish
Plus okay I didn't think the advantage
man advantage over three but let's see
what happens rookie AIDS ah queenside
castle multi-purpose move getting out of
the pin and allowing rip d8 next move
okay it's good to know probably
should've seen that a bit quicker anyway
we can see I can just prove here that
after even after a Bishop g3 uh why this
is just a bit better here I guess f6 is
a main move but then still after
something like ninety five say Bishop
before check c3 Bishop a5 I would expect
white queenside castle here I can
probably reinforce the evaluation the
stockfish white is doing quite well so
anyway I hope that brings some insight
into some new line especially this line
with I take you for followed by 1985 is
not so common and I think a lot of
players
can very easily study a lot of openings
and just never encounter something like
this and it's exactly what happened to
me back when I was kind of a mid 2200
level player and calculate this for the
first time and it's one of these things
it's good to kind of know least know for
white if you're an e4 player know this
Knight c3 line especially know up to
Bishop g3 if you know this far then
you'll be in very good shape and if
you're looking for a tricky opening for
black I can I can recommend this in
English as as a lot of white players
will maybe start thinking in in this
position so anyway I hope you guys
enjoyed that uh if you have any requests
to see different types of content or you
have questions I'm gonna try and make
more content exclusive for YouTube
because I know the audience is growing
so stay tuned and I'll see you in the
next video